[Música]
domingo à noite é muito bom estar aqui e
eu vou começar com uma pergunta afinal o
que é a tecnologia do que trata porque
não tem uma figura de um dinossauro não
a gente estuda populações humanas
arqueologia ao estudo do antigo mas
arquivo pestre faz parte da arqueologia
como uma simbolização dessas populações
que no caso por exemplo do paraná podem
ter até 15 mil anos ea gente tem
representações a dessa arte rupestre
aqui no estado
datadas com placas que caíram de abrigos
né
temos a cerca de 400 sítios
arqueológicos com um pintura rupestre no
paraná mas 50 com gravuras né esse saque
a a são no parque estadual do guartelá
que vocês agendando vão poder conhecer
né o parque é público né e mas afinal de
contas essa arqueologia e arte rupestre
sempre está relacionada a um grupo lá
para trás da ong que a surgem todos
esses dados na será que só aqui a no sul
do brasil a gente só tem algumas cenas
isoladas
é diferente do nordeste bem por isso que
a eu acho que eu me tornei a arqueóloga
porque eu queria entender melhor como
que essa informação chegava e porque que
era tão inacessível
nela pode ter esse passado pode ter
muito tempo mas ele está tão próximo da
gente é muitas vezes a gente tem e
sepultamentos humanos no quintal né eu
vou explicar para vocês isso
que vocês vêem o uma ponta de lança de
quase 20 centímetros que é uma raridade
no na américa do sul e que pode estar
relacionado há 10 mil anos puxa mas a
ong que tá essa ponta vocês podem
conhecer o museu paranaense instituição
que eu logo que eu comecei a minha
graduação na universidade federal do
paraná
eu comecei está já e passaram 35 anos e
aqui um pequeno vasilhame que só
sobreviveu à ação do tempo
a gente tá falando de populações humanas
e de vestígios que conseguem sobreviver
à ação do tempo é isso que trata a
arqueologia seja uma casa né
por exemplo o quintal do museu
paranaense é a praça ali que tem o
belvedere colocar uns tapumes ligaram
pra mim perguntando cláudia você acha
que pode ter alguma coisa
meu deus ali era uma área de uma antiga
capela nénão não chegou a ser construída
há há há
a igreja mas havia uma capela e até a
metade do século 19 até 1850 não existia
há cemitérios públicos
a maior parte das pessoas era sepultada
dentro das igrejas dentro das capelas né
e aqui em curitiba nesta central aliás
pessoas já devem ter passeado ali do
lado do meu ver dele e de repente a a25
30 centímetros estava lá do lado de
canos já tinha sepultamentos né com mais
de 200 anos
a agente só fez a intervenção porque ea
vai ser colocado um elevador neva está
sendo criado um espaço mais aberto ao
público mas como vocês podem perceber se
eu tô falando sepultamento de 200 anos o
arqueólogo também trabalha com a
população histórica
muitas vezes a gente tenta testar o
nosso conhecimento
analisando
acho que a gente produz porque
normalmente o que o arqueólogo a têm
acesso são os destaques né
então vejam o lixo que vocês produzem né
se eles dão conta do universo todo que
vocês têm isso é pro mundo inteiro né
e aqui na a quando a gente tem essas
atividades de campo e sempre tem que ter
autorização de pesquisa têm que ter um
local na hora que deu o endosso que vai
guardar esse material né
muitas vezes aqui a arqueóloga tarde
isolada porque estavam construindo uma
uma uma garagem e infelizmente já não
deu o tempo de a gente chegar porque era
uma urna funerária guarani que tinha
ossos mas as pessoas acreditam sempre
nessa existência de hipóteses de ouro
não é infelizmente eles a avião já
destruindo quase tudo né a gente só
chegou para retirar o vasilhame já quase
inteiro quebrado é e aquino
provavelmente era tinha um sepultamento
primário seja em que eu quase todos
dentro do novo vasilhame né
quando que um sítio arqueológico que
essa área onde tem esses vestígios pode
trazer mais informação
é quando aparece junto essas
representações simbólicas a parte do
imaginário dessas populações
então por isso eles são tão importantes
você espera podem pensar puxa com que
uma pintura sobrevive 78 mil anos mas
tem algumas que são muito mais recentes
em 500 anos e aqui no paraná as
primeiras pinturas que foram estudadas
sistematicamente foram no abrigo fazenda
das cavernas em 1954 por arqueólogos
franceses
haneke josé antenor a e vocês vêem é que
são a bem vocês já devem ter visto
imagens muito parecidas talvez até de
outros locais né que são aqueles
serviços em fila ainda por um cercado né
e como que essas pinturas né que é aaa
se achavam que no paraná
a gente só tinha cenas isoladas e que
não tinha a capacidade de a somar muito
mais ao conhecimento né afinal de contas
e de 1954 até a 2014 quando foram
descobertas novas a áreas e que vocês
vão ver a diferença né
aqui embaixo também vocês vêem é uma
foto é da iaa a mesma foto a gente passa
um filtro
nesse caso de estresse mas pode ser só
com saturação e você consegue ter a
através de filtros óticos através da
análise espectral a gente consegue ter a
composição química então são sempre
equipes muito grandes né o arqueólogo
ele não trabalha nunca sozinho sempre
são equipes e aqui né foi um dos locais
dentro desses meus 35 anos de a subida
descida e e conhecer a 300 municípios
aqui no paraná alguns no mato grosso
outros e santa catarina
néné eu acho que quando a gente gosta
muito do que a gente faz a gente também
quer transformar esse conhecimento em
alguma coisa mais acessível à população
néné e 1992 estava chovendo a gente
estava desenvolvendo o trabalho próximo
a essa área e não dava mais pra escavá
na no abrigo que a gente tava
trabalhando então a gente resolveu
percorrer a áreas próximas e chegou até
esse
local foi desses assim a escapa porque
isso é em 2014
néné em 1992 nos levaram a um lugar era
muito alto 67 metros de altura ea
chamado pedra do relógio porque parecia
que tinha um relógio né com aqueles há
aqueles tracinhos do minuto né a foto
que eu tirei aquela máquina simples não
era mecânica e estava chovendo e eu quis
voltar eu voltei 22 anos seguidos nem
consegui mais entrar eu tinha
autorização de pesquisa mas não queria
brigar com as pessoas pra entrar até que
um dia eu consegui nem eu tinha
autorização de pesquisa e conseguir
entrar
e daí não tinha ainda essa escada subir
numa pedra escalei uma árvore né
cheguei a cinco metros é o tubo é e de
onde tirei essa fotografia aquela pedra
do relógio na verdade tinha uma grande o
cobra a interpretação na pintura
rupestre em sítios com pintura rupestre
é muito complicado porque a gente está
mudo mexendo com uma diversidade
cultural né então com cabeças e
cervídeos na do sexo masculino porque
ser vídeo com chifre é só dou essa uns
indivíduos masculinos né e uma cena
fantástica com 125 figuras humanas né a
como a dançar é um mito de origem mito
de criação que está colocado e foi
divulgado e ganha uma relevância
internacional
os principais livros didáticos de
arqueologia brasileira já estão com essa
imagem do município de piraí do sul no
paraná
então em cima dessa 125 figuras humanas
têm sá
o que a gente chama de seres fantásticos
né são animais mas com comportamento
humano né dançando néel quem chocalho a
como em uma proporção muito
pior do que aqueles a do que as figuras
humanas que cada uma tem um prazo pra
cima pra baixo é como a na hora que eu
fiz um zoom com a câmera fotográfica eu
fiquei
é como se tivesse acontecido uma mágica
é foi muito foi uma experiência
transformadora e também da mesma forma
que a gente tem esses grandes paredões
com com locais inacessíveis e por isso
que esse conhecimento acabou só sendo
recuperado em 2014 e mostrou que
realmente a gente tem que sair fora da
zona de conforto e buscar informações
novas né a o passado é mal conhecido né
mal documentado né porque a gente é tem
uma uma série de barreiras a se
enfrentar mas eu acho que à medida que a
se você quiser eu acho que você consegue
né e com uma equipe de pesquisadores
dedicados né eu coordeno uma equipe
fantástica então a gente consegue aqui
também no ano de 2014 eu acho que a
colheita de informações foi muito legal
né
a gente também conseguiu registrar
plantas domesticadas que aqui para o sul
do brasil ainda não vi haviam sido a
caracterizada aqui um pé de milho
naquele pequeno abrigo e esse ano 2019
impede mandioca e provavelmente uma
peneira pra a fazer o beijo né
há como eu trabalho no museu paranaense
de ter um rico acervo etnográfico é uma
hipótese a ser pensada mas esse sítio
está sendo estudado
esse também faz parte desse mesmo sítio
tem vários sinais geométricos muitos são
estilizações tem insetos na aqui é essa
aqui se fosse olhar com um detalhe seria
uma centopéia
néné e na mitologia gente também tem
formigas porque são seres que conseguem
a conviver com a morte e por isso são
considerados por muitos grupos como
seres sobrenaturais né
e aqui também outro abrigo para vocês
verem com a importância da tecnologia da
que chega né
quando a gente é antigamente a gente
tinha que tirar milhares de fotografias
e depois tentar mexer manualmente pra a
a conseguir contraste agora gente com a
máquina digital já vi na hora
como fica a gente já pode apostar na na
rede social nela tirar uma self aprovar
nenhum eu que achei primeiro nesse local
né
é como se tivesse alguma importância
tanto né mas é e aqui vocês vêem essa é
a mesma imagem aqui tá com uma hiper
saturação né então aqui vocês vêem a
cabeça do serviço de como ele está todo
decorado aqui vocês não vêem nada né
e também há como em alguns grandes
projetos na esse foi em 95 a 98 no vale
do baixo iguaçu
lá a foi documentado essa grande a área
era um cerca de 500 gravar 500 gravuras
rupestres né
gravuras daí podem ter pinturas
associadas a gente usou mesmo com
máquinas mecânicas né infravermelho
filme infravermelho filma filme
ultravioleta que até pra você conseguir
a importação naquela época tinha que ter
autorização do exército era super
complicado mas a gente conseguiu fazer
essa documentação e como não tinha há
como preservar a gente conseguiu fazer a
moldagem né a ficou preservado debaixo
da água a 12 metros de profundidade como
usina hidrelétrica
normalmente tem 1 100 anos
de duração que consite protegido para o
futuro
e aqui são alguns blocos o museu
regional do iguaçu que vocês podem
visitar uma parte desse material
e aqui é uma parte de como foi feita a
moldagem de duas toneladas de silicone
né dada ocorrem do brasil não podia
chover pra fazer a cura do material e
foi o ano que a era medido em 50 anos
foi o júlio que mais choveu nessa região
então eles imaginam o meu desespero pelo
amor de deus
e aqui é um grande convite pra vocês
vocês têm na cidade de curitiba o
terceiro museu mais antigo do país que
foi fundado em 1876 está na 7ª série
é um museu a entrada é gratuita vamos lá
conhece um pouquinho mais dessa fim
pinturas rupestres
vocês podem acessar pelo site do museu
ou pela exposição física na vamos
escavar um pouquinho mais a nossa
história perceber a riqueza dela e ver
como a gente consegue fazer as suas
pontes né dessas memórias flutuantes e
convergentes pra uma narrativa universal
[Aplausos]